So, I've got a hot tip for you all.
There is actually a PO trick that is
going to open up more doors than you
could possibly imagine and is going to
appear in more places than you could
possibly conceive of. This PO trick is
called a linear isolation. And it may
not look like much, but it is your key
for getting into everything from
anti-pin flowers to snakes and body
tracers to even things like love lacing
and the like. How could this possibly
be? I'll break it down for you in this
video.
>> [music]
[music]
>> Drex here from Drex Factor PO sharing
with you the love of PO spinning and
flow arts to benefit your body and
brain. And in this video, we're going to
explore the wonderful world of linear
isolations and find out why they're so
versatile. But before we dive in, I just
want to give a quick shout out to the
friends of the channel. Big thanks to
Dark Monk, Fire Mecca, Flowfests, Flow
Toys, Pyroer, Light Toys, and Ultraoy
for helping to make the videos on this
channel possible. You can learn more
about all these awesome companies and
the work that they're doing to support
flow artists like yourself by checking
out the links that I have down in the
description of this here video. All
right, so first bit of business out of
the way. What exactly is linear
isolation? If you already know what a
linear isolation is, feel free to skip
ahead to the next section. But if you
need an explainer, here is a brief
overview. Linear isolations involve
carrying the hand back and forth across
the body in multiple beats of the poi,
always in a straight line. You want to
make sure that you are doing no more
than three beats as you go back and
forth here. I do a beat left, bottom,
right, left, bottom, right. As I'm going
back and forth, and of course, there's
that little bit where the po pokes out
above my hand as it sneaks on back to
the left. I can also do a linear
isolation with my hand going up and down
in a vertical line or I can do a linear
isolation across a diagonal like so. The
rules still apply. I've done several
tutorials that involve the use of a
linear isolation, but I will link to one
of them that explains both linear
isolations and extensions up in the
cards as well as down in the description
if you'd like to catch up. Now, I'm
certainly not the first one to point out
just how useful linear isolations are.
In fact, a lot of the material in this
video is cribed directly from a class
that alien John taught years ago. And
I'm sure that he actually got a lot of
that information from other people, too.
Who even coined the term, I don't know.
But what I can tell you is that these
are PO tricks that get all over the map
and touch pretty much every type of PO
tech that you can possibly imagine. So,
let's dive in. The first and I would
argue probably most helpful use for
linear isolations is in learning how to
perform four pedal anti-pin flowers and
specifically anti-pin flowers in diamond
mode. When I was first learning how to
do anti-pin flowers, they were pretty
difficult. You had to try to learn how
to control the number of beats that you
were doing as you were moving your hand
around opposite the direction of the
poi. There was nothing else really like
them in the poi world and we would
occasionally fall into something that I
refer to as beat locking. that is trying
to keep the poi moving at a constant
rate as your hand goes around. But
linear isolations are an excellent way
of getting around beat locking. So, how
do we turn a linear isolation into a
four pedal anti-pin flower? It's
surprisingly simple. All I have to do is
add some up and down motion with my
hands. Namely, as the pyer is going down
across the middle, I let my hand go down
with it. And as it goes up across the
middle going back the other way, my hand
goes up with it, too. So basically, we
take this straight line that we started
with in a linear isolation and we expand
it out into a full circle as though
we've blown it up like a balloon. This
gives us a diamond mode four pedal
anti-pin flower. And this technique is
so effective that I have used it to
teach countless beginners, some of whom
have just picked up their first set of
poi over the years, how to get down four
pedal anti-pin flowers. It is incredibly
useful. This technique does actually
work the other way, too. If say I wanted
to get to a two- pedal inspin flower, I
could say have my hand go up as the
poise going down and down as the poise
going up. And now I've gotten to what is
the inverse pattern of a four pedal
anti-pin flower, which is a two- pedal
inspin. In fact, using linear isolations
to learn both patterns is a great way to
understand how they're really inverses
of each other. It's pretty cool. Another
poet trick that linear isolations are
super helpful for learning is how to
perform snakes. a specific type of body
tracing that can be done either up the
body or across the body like so. And if
you're paying close attention, you've
probably already seen where the key to
this lies. When we're performing the
linear isolation going from side to
side, we have those moments where the PO
pokes out above and below the hand. When
we turn this into a snake, we're taking
those moments and we're wrapping them
around the body. So, when I drop the poi
down, it goes back behind my shoulder.
And when I pop the poi up, it goes under
my armpit. It's really the same pattern
as this, just wrapped around my shoulder
as I go back and forth. You can use this
to perform snakes across your body like
so in split time, same direction, or in
split time opposites, going back and
forth from stage left to stage right and
back again. You can also use this
technique vertically to get down your
vertical snakes and come up and down if
you so choose. There's a bunch of
different options here. learn them all
because this is a surprisingly versatile
way of getting into body tracing and
making it look good. Okay, so arguably
flowers and body tracers have quite a
lot in common. What else can you learn
how to do with linear isolations?
Well, one of the most surprising places
that I found to use linear isolations is
with love lacing. Let me show you what I
mean here. There's an entire family of
poi inversions that involve taking the
poi between our arms like so. This
particular version is called a barrel
roll, but there's also a version called
a love lace. What makes each of them
unique is the pattern that they create
when you pull them apart. When I perform
a barrel roll like so, if I pull the poi
apart, they turn into a tangle like so.
It would turn into something like an
orbital if I had swivels in my handles.
On the other hand, if I'm performing a
love lace, when I pull them apart, they
just spin freely. In fact, when you
perform a love lace, you can, if you
want to, just perform them as an
isolation in the middle and the PO never
even intersect with each other. Okay, so
then how exactly do linear isolations
help us get there? So, it turns out that
the key for differentiating between a
barrel roll and a love lace is a linear
isolation. Let me show you why. When I'm
entering into a barrel roll, I'm aiming
to get the PO coming from on top to get
past the arm that's out in front of me.
And then it has to pass around that arm
to get around and initiate the little
nexus point of the barrel roll like so.
And of course, by doing so, I've also
created a twist in my arms and poi. Now,
if I want to avoid making the twist
happen, rather than aiming the poi for
just past my arm, I instead want to
perform a linear isolation right before
it reaches my arm. What this does is it
creates a moment in which the two poi
can wrap around each other without
having to tangle like so. And this also
means that I can keep the love lace
going as long as I want to. It's a
really helpful tool and it's a
surprising way in which linear
isolations get hidden inside of a piece
of old poe that predates the naming of
them. And if you need a better visual on
that, here we go. When I'm getting into
the barrel roll, again, I'm aiming the
PO just past my arm to get around it.
And when I'm performing the love lace, I
boom, pop the PO down before it can get
in. And of course, part of the fun of
getting into a love lace is just keeping
the thing going forever in a day. Pretty
cool, right? Now, linear isolations are
not just useful for getting down older
school tech like love lacing. It also
turns out they're good for newer stuff
like gunslingers. Let me show you how.
Gunslingers and Meteor are fundamentally
the same concept, namely that we're
spinning an object that has two ends to
it that are coming out of either side of
our hand. When we do it with
gunslingers, it just so happens that it
is twice as fast and twice as small. But
my favorite gunslinger trick of all
time, that is the anti- spin flower
turns out to make use of our linear
isolations. And if you remember the
first entry on this list, I'm sure you
can see where this is going. Namely, we
want to learn how to do waist straps
with our gunslingers. That is, take them
back and forth across our bodies. And
the key to this, it turns out, is doing
linear isolations. Namely, as I'm going
from my forward side on my stage right
to my reverse side on my stage left, the
way to do it is that I have to pop up my
thumb end in order to let the pinky in
past it and initiate this reverse weave.
By the same token, when I want to go
back from my stage left to my stage
right, I have to perform a linear
isolation with my pinky end. So, it's
thumb linear isolation, pinky linear
isolation, thumb linear isolation,
pinky. We can go straight back and forth
between the two sides between a thumbled
and a pinkyled two beat weave. From
there, it's just a matter of taking our
hand up and down in order to get to that
flower, which of course looks pretty
stylish, don't you think? I actually
spent close to 2 months working on
gunslinger flowers before I realized
that linear isolations were the key to
going back and forth across your body,
much less the fact that the gunslinger
flowers were really just two gunslinger
weaves that were tied together. So y'all
get to benefit from my hard work and my
confusion from years ago as you're
working on this stuff yourselves. And
for our final entry on this list, I
would love to introduce you to a certain
po trick that I learned from a man named
Sidil Human that involves performing a
piouette as the poi isolate around your
head. And yes indeed, this involves a
linear isolation, too. So, I'm going to
give you both the half turn version of
this as well as the full turn version.
For the half turn version, we are
spinning our PO counterclockwise. And
I'm going to turn my body just slightly
to my stage right. I'm going to bring my
right hand poi to perform that linear
isolation behind my head and my left
hand poi to perform the linear isolation
straight in front of me. As I do that, I
turn to my left and I bring both poi out
to either side. I can of course do the
same thing going the other way. Thinking
right behind and then left behind. I can
think right behind and then think left
behind. Or I can do this as a full turn.
In which case I'm starting from
clockwise. And what I want to do is hit
that linear isolation in the middle and
perform a full pyouette around it like
so. Take your pick of which you prefer.
I personally like the full one, but the
half one is also pretty snazzy as well.
So, there you go. We've covered
everything from flowers to inversions,
as well as gunslinger tech and even some
cool dance related stuff. Linear
isolations are surprisingly useful, and
we've barely scratched the surface on
what they're capable of here. What was
your favorite use for linear isolations
that I showed off in this video? Leave
me a comment and let me know. Also, be
sure to like, share, and subscribe to
help other people find this video. and
to help my channel grow.
[music]
This video and all the videos on this
channel would not be possible without my
amazing supporters on Patreon. In
particular, I want to give a huge shout
out to my flow patrons who are listed on
screen right now. Thank you so much. You
all rock. And if you out there watching
want to get your name in the credits or
access to a host of other awesome
rewards, you can do that by checking out
my Patreon over at
patreon.com/drexfactorpo
and signing up. I'll include a link to
it up in the cards as well as down in
the description. Please help me out in
my mission to bring po spinning and flow
arts to the whole wide world. Thank you
in advance. And if you'd like a little
further explanation on how to
differentiate between those pesky barrel
rolls and love laces, I did an entire
video on just that that includes some
really stunning slow-mo visuals. So, I
will go ahead and link to that up here
on screen as well as down in the
description. Thank you so much for
watching. Make sure to get out and flow
today and I'll see you with a new video
real soon. [music] Take care now. Peace.